now speaking of things going on in
Tennessee right now you know about the
uh the riot
I'm sorry the peaceful wonderful protest
that's that's what it's it's a peaceful
wonderful protest when it's the
Democrats
uh leading people in to interrupt
legislative procedures and it's a
terrible insurrection
when conservative grannies go take
pictures in the capital rotunda that's
what happens so
now we we've we're trying to figure out
who these people are
there were three reps who pushed this
nonsense
one of whom is a Woman by the name of
Gloria Johnson Gloria Johnson is one of
the three she's the only one who managed
to survive the expulsion vote she
survived it by one vote the other two
got booted out of the state house but
she survived it by one vote because she
was slightly less egregious in her
behavior on that day so these are the
kind of people who are running the show
in New York uh Gloria Johnson
uh just recently made the claim that
the conservatives in Tennessee are
trying to bring back lynching was just a
few weeks ago that one of my colleagues
in our criminal justice committee
um we were we had a bill they have a
bill to bring back the firing squad and
the electric chair and one of my
colleagues said I think we should bring
back hanging by a tree
um he literally suggested lynching
it's happening in Tennessee by the way I
said it was New York because of This
Woman's crazy ideas but no that that's
what a Tennessee lawmaker is saying
that's not what lynching is
lynching is
extrajudicial killing by a group of
people
lynching does not always involve hanging
lynch mobs can Lynch people all sorts of
different ways
in hanging
does not always mean lynching
in fact most of the time hanging has not
meant lynching
but most of the time hanging has just
been the punishment for a crime meted
out by the courts if a criminal is tried
and convicted
and then hanged you wouldn't call that a
lynching that is just the ordinary
administration of justice
this woman doesn't know a basic fact
about the justice system
and it makes me wonder how long
can we govern ourselves with ignorance
this pervasive
how long
can we continue this Republic of ours
when people and especially our leaders
don't know a thing about anything they
don't know I'm not saying that they have
kind of eccentric ideas or that we would
disagree on this I mean they just don't
know basic facts about anything they
don't know what a man is they don't know
what a woman is how long can we endure
our constitution is great it's a really
nice piece of paper with really nice
fancy handwriting on it but it doesn't
mean anything if there are not people to
run the government properly
and we have such blight ignorance in
this country especially among the
leadership class I don't know how much
longer we can go on like this now the
other person who helped lead the
Tennessee riot a guy named Justin
Pearson
Justin Pearson is a preacher I guess in
addition to being a
former politician a guy who used to have
a seat in the state house but now got
booted out
here is the way that Pearson preaches
would you mind going ahead and praying
with me now mother God create a God
loving God holy God take this your
servant made from dust and connect it
with the raw materials of Stardust to
speak in this moment to say something
that brings forward the word you've
placed into my heart I accept my
unworthiness for such a task as bold as
this and I seek your guidance as you use
me and speak through me to the ancestor
preachers who made sermons from hymns
moans and groans and spirituals from the
bondage of slavery speak now through
this your descendant to the black women
locked out being abused tormented raped
eradicated and yet born a new and
distant future in this country into a
young colored boy named me I name you
now my great-grandmother Anna Ruth my
great-grandmother flossie my
great-grandmother everline my
great-grandmother Lavinia yeah he goes
on and on
slam poetry is the death of Art
it would seem to be the death of
religious worship
and it's now also the death of politics
he opens up he says mother God these
people who insist that we honor their
pronouns their preferred pronouns they
won't honor God's preferred pronouns
they never seem to do that why does it
matter why does it matter what this
guy's religious views are
or irreligious views I guess in this
case
because as John Adams told us the
Constitution is built for a moral and
religious people and when he's talking
about religion he's talking about
Christianity not mother God ancestor
worship or whatever this guy's talking
about but actual Christianity not the uh
what what is this place called the
Memphis Unitarian Universalist meeting
house but Christianity John Adams
spelled that out he said the the beliefs
that Anime America are Christian beliefs
the morality that animates America it's
Christian morality John Jay said this
the founding fathers said this
resoundingly
why is a politician a preacher it I'm
not on him because he's a preacher of
course government is in the religion
business
how and who and what we worship more
than anything else forms Who We Are
if we worship God we're going to have a
godlier goodlier better Society
if we worship
money we're going to have a
materialistic Society if we worship
weird sex stuff we're going to have a
lust convulsed Society
if we if we worship ourselves we're in a
very selfish Society
in that sermon he goes on he talks about
how important it is to trans everybody
they won't have to worry about folks
talking about advocating for people to
get access to health care who are
transgender children
won't have to worry about the need to
end lynching as capital punishment okay
oh there it is too oh man the first time
all I caught was the the need to trans
people and by the way children he says
we listen we need to I'm praying to the
mother goddess of the spirit of my
ancestors and that is why we need to
chop off the healthy genitals of the
little children and that is why we need
to pump them full of cross-sex hormones
and sterilize the children because of my
religious views and that is why we need
to stop lynching as capital punishment
lynching cannot be capital punishment by
definition
split it capital punishment is a part of
the judicial system
if a person has a
Fair trial a real trial and is convicted
by the Civil Authority by the judicial
system and is then killed that cannot be
lynching
by definition these are the people who
are running our states
and this is going to be increasingly the
case this is a young man he's in his mid
to late 20s
this is it's not his fault that he was
poorly educated it's not his fault that
he was raised in some Bizarro
pseudo-religious upbringing
it's not
it's not his fault that this was how he
was formed
it's not his fault but it is our problem
our leaders
are just so profoundly ignorant
they have no idea
and
when all of our leaders have no idea our
country cannot fly
the Constitution was built for a moral
and religious people I'll add one little
extra to that
it was built for people who knew
the most basic facts of reality
okay the rest of the show continues now
we've got a really important video for
woke Wednesday this is the love
don't judge the latest love don't judge
video in which my producer Ben Davies
wants to see how long I cannot judge
and how long you cannot judge whatever
is in this video become a member use
code Knowles Canada wlas a checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]